te voilà l'année des guignols un
jean-pierre ça peut tout faire
le dvd les messieurs quand vous voyez ça
vous pensez à la sueur qui est derrière
chez moi j'étais pas là moi non mais ça
nous fait quoi ça nous fait beaucoup
moins rigoler que quand on l'a sorti
dans le bureau mais c'est un peu comme
ça c'est un peu comme ça tous les jours
c'est à dire que ça nous fait beaucoup
plus marrer l'après midi quand on essaie
de chercher lalanne plutôt que le soir
qu'on s'est diffusée ouais c'est un peu
normal maison aussi j'ai remarqué en
relisant toutes vos interviews pour
préparer cette émission que vous posez
toujours les mêmes questions
alors je vais faire pareil on va les
faire une fois pour toutes ce sera la
dernière fois que vous y répondre est
d'accord le problème c'est que vous avez
30 secondes maximum pour répondre serge
tu prends des tops à 30 secondes une
coupe quand un vrai peut-on tout pensé
top oui non sanaa les outils pour penser
oui je vais inviter toutes les deux
semaines chez relie son attention
doit-on tout dire top oui non numérotées
alors moi je suis méfiant des guignols
donc si on a les outils et qu'il en
reste un petit peu de ces outils qu'on
tourne à penser et ben oui on peut tout
dire mais il faut pouvoir articuler sa
pensée et c'est comme ça tous les jours
est vachement mieux la réponse
non ils vont prendre la tête comme ça
j'ai une valve marrante oui mais tu
comprends si jamais c'est insupportable
donc doit-on tout dire tu pense que oui
toi ouais je pense qu'on peut tu penses
que gollnisch avait raison ah ah ouais
mais la joie une autre question à une
seule question c'est une autre question
vas-y tu penses que gollnisch a eu
raison de dire ce qu'elle a dit je pense
pas qu'il a raison de dire ce qu'il a
dit je pense qu'il a le droit de le dire
pour peu qu'on puisse à la fois le
critiquer a apporté un matériel critique
suffisant pour les gens qui pourraient
de son avis c'est celle assez simple
c'est ça la liberté d'expression c'est
de pouvoir laisser s'exprimer les gens
avec qui on n'est absolument pas
d'accord encore faut-il pouvoir les
contredire dans un dans un cadre à la
propriété encore du temps et 10 mois et
guti l'yonne le commissaire européen qui
dit que finalement l'homosexualité c'est
un péché que les enfants ont besoin
d'une maman et tout ça il a le droit de
le dire mais lui c'est un italien il a
tous les droits
à la question la plus folle la plus
faste partout est-ce que l'humour est
forcément drôle top si c'est moi qui
fait des vannes en moi je peux répondre
oui oui la preuve que non elle apporte
encore la preuve alors je vous souhaite
chien s'il en reste est ce que est ce
que bruno gaccio et si vous touchez
dessin top oui non
oh
où